further while the skull bone does not
itself feel it seems that perhaps a more
specific significance could still be
found for it in the fact that specific
feelings through their proximity to the
skull might enable us to ascertain what
it is that the skull means to convey and
when a conscious mode of spirit has its
feeling in a specific area of the skull
the shape of this part of the skull
might perhaps indicate what that mode is
and what it's what is its special nature
just as for example some people complain
of feeling a painful tension somewhere
in the head when they are thinking hard
or even when thinking at all so two
could steal in committing murder writing
poetry and so on each be accompanied by
its own feeling which besides would
necessarily be located in its own
special place this area of the brain
which would in this way be more moved
and activated would probably also
develop the adjacent area of the skull
bone or again this particular area would
from sympathy or consensus not be inert
but would enlarge or diminish itself or
modify its shape in some way or other
what however makes this hypothesis
improbable as this that feeling as such
is something indeterminate and feeling
in the head as the center might be a
general sympathetic feeling accompanying
all forms of suffering so then mixed up
with the thief's murderers poets hettich
angry headache our other feelings which
could be it could as little be
distinguished from one another and also
from those we can call merely bodily
feelings as an illness can be diagnosed
from the symptom of headache if we
restrict its significance merely to the
bodily aspect
in the course of the discussion during
the previous paragraphs Hagel was first
criticizing physiognomies as a
pseudoscience why is it a pseudoscience
it can't really yield us intelligibility
and necessity like a genuine science is
supposed to do and then he turned to
phrenology and now we're knee-deep in
the middle of that he's already levied
some pretty damning criticisms against
the discipline or pseudo science of
phrenology which focuses on the skull
and on you know recesses or bumps or
other features of the skull bone which
are supposed to signify something about
the composition of the brain which then
is in turn supposed to signify something
about the nature of the person whose
brain it is so here in paragraph 334
he's going to consider another
possibility that the phrenologist might
be bringing up and he's going to show us
why this doesn't really work so the
phrenologist can say sure the skull bone
itself doesn't have any feeling doesn't
have any sensation it is you know to a
certain respect a dead thing like you've
been saying Hagel but we can still say
that there would be particular feelings
or in we should be very careful here
about the terminology Hagel says that
the skull bone itself does not feel
proven anything right but he doesn't say
good food for this what's translated
here is finding a feeling he says am
finding which is a bit more broad and
you could translate that perhaps as
sensations right and this works as well
so the skull itself doesn't as skull
have sensations you know what but it
hurts on my head when things happen well
that's the tissue surrounding the skull
it's not the the skull itself but we're
not worried about feelings of pain or
pleasure so much we're interested more
in other
types of feelings other types of
sensations and Hagel says okay so we're
going to now consider this possibility
so perhaps a more specific significance
could still be found in it in the fact
that specific feelings through their
proximity to the skull not in the skull
but to the skull might enable us to
ascertain what it is that the skull
means to convey remember what we're
dealing here with is a discipline which
says that the skull itself is in some
way meaningful significative and not
just in terms of like comparing skulls
against each other or charting out human
evolution or anything like that nor you
know for like forensic purposes oh this
skull is bashed in or people put holes
in it something must have been going on
there rather we're looking at the skull
as somehow meaningfully significative of
the person whose skull it is so allowing
us to say something about who that
person is what kind of person that they
are so he goes on and he says perhaps it
could be a [ __ ] that a conscious mode of
spirit has its feeling in a specific
area of the skull so a conscious mode of
spirit that covers a wide range here so
we're talking about everything from love
to being friendly to being antagonistic
to having artistic preferences to being
a Philistine to you know I mean we might
go down the line to even you know today
talk about genres of music or likings
for certain kinds of media materials
maybe those would have their own
particular correspondence in parts of
the skull you know because they have
their own particular sensations and it
could get quite elaborate there could be
a number of different things being laid
out but this is the general idea that
the skull itself would be the locus you
know holding all this goopy stuff in our
head
but the brain is really where this is
happening and the brain parts would be
corresponding to like we said specific
modes of spirit of mental activity of
Geist so he goes on and he says you
could have a feeling of specific area
the skull and then the Sheep of this
part of the skull might perhaps indicate
what that mode is and what is its
special nature so we're back again to
the skull being deformed in certain ways
from its otherwise ordinary shape to you
know concluding that it's because
something is going on with the brain
inside of the skull and we don't really
understand the process Hagel's already
you know made it kind of clear but also
in a joking way I was going to say made
kind of a joke before about well you
know why would it push out the skull why
not push in the skull the skull is
harder than the brain why doesn't the
skull just constrain the brain and we
don't have an explanation for the
mechanism of how this is supposed to
happen but the foreknowledge estar
saying well look we know that we have
different mental faculties and different
activities and different propensity
those could in some way through the
medium of the brain be connected to
regions of the skull and their
particular determinations so he says
let's you know take an example some
people complain of feeling a painful
tension somewhere in the head when they
are thinking hard or even when thinking
at all right this is true some people
get headaches from thinking some people
do feel a kind of tension when thinking
is going on we in fact you localize are
our psychical processes it's not always
in the head sometimes we say we feel
things in the chest or in our guts right
or our hands clenched because we're
angry it's not just that the body is
flooding us with you know adrenaline or
anything like that this is a psychical
thing you know that anger is represented
in the hands but we're talking about the
here and we could say all right so some
people do in fact get headaches when
they have to think hard what does that
prove what does that actually give us
first of all it doesn't push their head
out or anything like that right the way
the phrenologist are hoping that it
would do nor does a shrink the skull in
on them although we may have a you know
sort of sensation like that when we feel
very tense but that's really in the
tissues rather than in the skull and the
brain now here's where he go goes with
this he says okay so let's accept that
some people do in fact have a physical
bodily manifestation of pain or tension
when they're thinking hard then maybe
there could also be things like
characteristic behavior stealing
committing murder writing poetry and so
on maybe each of these would be
accompanied by its own particular
feeling which then would be localized in
part of the brain and then would have to
do with the skull by by pushing it out
or deforming it or making it round or
flatter or something like that each
would be localized in its own special
place so following out this logic he
says this area of the brain which would
in this way be more moved and activated
would probably also develop the adjacent
area of the skull bone this is one of
the fundamental conceptions of
phrenology murderers should have a
certain feeling localized in the brain
which then does something to the skull
bone and so by looking at the skulls of
people you could tell what their
characteristic behavior ought to be
murder other people poet right you know
poetry writers notice Hagel doesn't say
good poets are bad poets okay I suppose
anybody who self-identifies as a poet
can fit the bill for this or anybody who
does write poetry whether it's good
poetry and captivates us or total drivel
that you know we walk out of the
coffeehouse saying this is nonsense I'm
not listening to this stuff that would
have its own specific area of the brain
with its own particular feeling and that
again would push on part of the skull or
pull on part of the skull or affected in
some way so you could look at somebody
and say AHA that person is going to be a
poet and you know presumably murderous
poets would have both parts developed
right and you can say well that guy's of
poets on the one hand if you like poetry
that's great on the other hand don't
walk down the dark alley with him
because he's a murderer so Hagel says
this area of the brain which would in
this way be more moved and activated
would probably develop the adjacent area
the skull bone we're again this
particular area would from sympathy or
consensus not be inert but would enlarge
or diminish itself or modify its shape
in some way or another that's another
possibility so you know you feel poetry
and you're in your veins that part of
your brain swells up and gets big or
maybe contracts or maybe moves around
from side to side we don't really know
which we're just sort of assuming until
we do brain studies on this sort of
thing and brain studies are a little
artificial at least at this point in
time when we have to put people into MRI
machines or hook them up to electrodes
we're not getting real spontaneous data
although you know we would try to adjust
for that but now think back to hegel's
time before we could crack people's
heads open and actually see the the what
was going on in there before they're
dead let alone put them inside of these
massive machines to you know make images
of what's going on at least as far as
the electrical activity in their brain
we're just sort of shooting you know
ideas out there and saying yeah maybe
part of the brain does this corresponds
to this activity stealing killing
writing poetry being a great lover being
a terrible lover being good with my
being bad with money pursuing ambition
you know all these sorts of things does
it really work Hagel says no and so
here's his criticism he says what makes
this hypothesis improbable this is a
hypothesis but it's improbable is this
feeling as such is something
indeterminate and feeling in the head as
the center might be a general
sympathetic feeling accompanying all
forms of suffering so that mixed up with
the thieves or murderers or poets head
itchy or headache or other feelings
which could could as little be
distinguished from one another and also
from those we call merely bodily
feelings as illnesses can be diagnosed
from the symptom of headache if we
restricted significance merely to the
bodily aspect so Hagel saying you know
it's it's fine as a hypothesis it fails
when we try to apply it because it's
it's just you know too messy there's so
many things going on in the the
conscious modes of spirit of the person
even if we take out bodily stuff you
know just completely bodily stuff and we
just attend to that it's already quite
complex now we add the body itself in we
can't be sure that any of this stuff
localized in some part of our head
really corresponds to what would be
going on in that part of the brain as a
matter of fact you know we know now that
the brain itself doesn't have that sort
of apparatus going on where it's pushing
things out and pulling things in unless
they're in a very gross way like is
somehow you know there's something else
going on with with a person's body so
this this is not going to work as a
hypothesis but Hagel is going to still
continue to examine how phrenology might
be able to justify itself because he has
to go through that that's what it means
to be critical you can't just throw
criticisms out there you have to aim
them right where the target is and
that's what he's doing in this case
in fact from whatever side we look at
the matter there is no necessary
reciprocal relation at all between them
nor any direct indication of such a
relation if all the same the relation is
still to exist what remains and is
necessary to form it is an irrational
free pre-established harmony of the
corresponding determination of the two
aspects for one of the two aspects is to
be a non spiritual reality a mere thing
on the one side then we have a multitude
of inert areas of the skull on the other
a multitude of mental properties whose
number and character will depend on the
state of psychology the more paltry the
conception of spirit the easier becomes
the task from this side for partly the
mental properties become fewer and
partly they become more detached rigid
and ossified and therefore more akin to
the characteristics of the bone and more
comparable with them but although the
task is made much easier by the paltry
conception of spirit yet there still
remains a very great deal to be done on
both sides there remains for observation
the entire contingency of their relation
if the children of Israel were likened
to number 2 the sands of the sea shore
would each take onto himself the grain
of sand which stood for him the
indifference in arbitrariness is such a
procedure would be no more glaring than
that which assigns to every faculty of
soul to every passion and what must
equally be considered here to each
nuance of character which the more
refined psychology and knowledge of
human nature likes to talk about its
particular area of skull and shape of
skull bone the skull of a murderer has
not this organ or even side but this
bump but this murderer has as well a
multitude of other properties just as he
has other bumps and along with the bumps
also Hallows when as a choice of bumps
and hollows and again his murders
disposition can be related to any bumper
hollow and this in turn to any mental
property for the murderer is neither
merely this abstraction of a murder
nor does he have only one bump and one
hollow the observations indulged in on
this point must just for that reason
sound as sensible as that of the dealer
and of the housewife about rain at the
annual fair and on washday dealer and
housewife might as well make the
observation that always rains what a
particular neighbor goes by or when they
eat roast pork just as rain is
indifferent to circumstances like these
so too from the standpoint of
observation a particular determinate
pneus of spirit is indifferent to a
particular formation of the skull for of
the two objects of this observation one
is a drive sapless being for itself an
ossified property of spirit the other is
an equally sapless being in itself such
an ossified thing as both are is
completely indifferent to everything
else it is just as much a matter of
indifference to the high bump whether a
murder is in its vicinity as it is to
the murder whether flatness is close by
him
here in paragraph 335 Hagel is levying
another major criticism against any
pretension of phrenology or anything
like it we ought to say it that's going
on in our own time to being in any in
any sense truly scientific and not just
scientific in hegel's broader sense of
you know this and shaft which includes
more than what we call the Natural
Sciences no but even if we just
concentrate on the natural science is
merely tabulating things on people's
heads and doing various you know
correlations between parts of the brain
that are being activated or not being
activated is not enough to actually
establish a science nor is doing
statistical modeling or there has to be
an intelligibility there has to be a
real connection going on or else what
one is doing is really essentially a
kind of intellectual play using using a
physical means and Hegel here is going
to talk about the relation he says
whatever side we look at the matter
there is no necessary reciprocal
relation at all between them what is the
them the brain parts and correspondingly
the mental properties that will talk
about and the parts of the skull or the
regions of the skull there is no
necessary reciprocal relationship
between them doesn't matter which side
we're actually looking at we're not
getting that the phrenologist is
assuming that as a hypothesis in order
to get going and then making up all
sorts of really cool charts and coming
up with you know examples of people but
it's not really a relation that that has
the character of a law it doesn't have
not just regularity but a kind of
necessity or intelligibility to why is
this connected with this why is this not
connected with this over here Hagel is
going to get to that in just a moment so
he says
if all the same the relation is still to
exist let's say that there is a relation
between them here's where a kind of
irrationality creeps in what remains in
is necessary to format is an irrational
not irrational but an irrational free
pre-established harmony of the
corresponding determination of the two
aspects if there really is some sort of
connection between the regions on the of
the skull what's observable and the
parts of the brain which are to some
degree observable but much less so we
don't really know what we're looking at
much of the time there can be a
connection but it becomes a connection
that doesn't have a why to it and if
it's lacking a why there's a problem
there we don't want just the that we
want to understand why are these things
connected in this way and not in that
way if we don't have that we don't have
genuine causality we don't have any sort
of true intelligibility the relation
becomes an irrational that we just
simply have to accept and we don't
really know what to do with it other
than perhaps manipulated you know push
this part in and see if that changes the
person or anything along those lines
there's a way of thinking about this if
we had to pick one term to sum up
Hagel's critique here its arbitrariness
will curly Hecht or veal Kerr in in
German right and if we want to be very
clever we can say what Hagel is saying
here is that vehicle a kite actuality
you know the actuality of this presumed
relation let's say that it is actual
becomes villachor you know vir click
eight villachor milk early you know we
could play around with the w's there we
don't have to do that necessarily we can
we can say that look the problem here is
that
this relationship is truly arbitrary how
can we demonstrate that Hagel goes on to
do that he says on the one side we have
a multitude of inert areas on the skull
on the other a multitude of mental
properties right and these are sort of
connected with the brain he says the
number and character of these will
depend on the state of psychology so if
we're focusing on this side over here we
have a discipline of psychology and
we've had this discipline around for a
long time by the way you know psychology
is originally part of philosophy goes
all the way back to Plato and Aristotle
right Aristotle's on the soul that we
call it the day anima it's you know
about the souhait the the soul the site
of the object of psychology right so
this investigation has been going on for
a very long time in the 19th century
we're going to see a great turn to you
know quantifying things and measuring
things and doing experimental psychology
but that's already going quite you know
quite well in the 18th century and Hagel
is is you know following up on this sort
of thing for nology is coming out of
this what psychology we have is going to
determine what mental properties we're
actually looking for let me give you an
example of how this might play itself
out so some people think and this is
what this is you know not only in
psychology but we can also call this a
philosophy of action that we simply have
desires or feelings we have effects and
we don't have any control over them they
drive us and then thoughts that we
happen to have about them are just you
know after the fact they may be
justifications they may be ways for us
to make sense of it right so that's a
particular psychology who holds that
sort of psychology david hume i think
thomas hobbes in a certain way holds
that psychology many other people have
as well an older psychology that is root
in virtue ethics says that we actually
do have some measure of control over
what we feel because there's there's
sort of some sort of reciprocal relation
between thinking the thoughts that we
have and feeling doesn't mean that we
can you know dictate everything about it
but it does mean that we can gradually
modify our desires to make them say more
rational or if you want to put in very
basic terms less likely to screw us up
even more than we currently are now
those are two different psychology's two
different ways of understanding the
psyches of human beings and they may in
fact have as families of psychology very
different understandings of how the
mental properties are interrelated with
each other which then ought to
presumably be reflected if they have
some sort of discussion of the brain
about how the brain is you know divided
up into its functions and then that in
turn would have to go to different areas
on the skull so if you've got a like
Hagel says if you've got a fairly
underdeveloped psychology he says the
more paltry the conception of spirit the
easier becomes a task from this side
what does he mean by paltry conception
of spirit he doesn't just mean not
having a lot of different functions he
means something like thinking well we're
basically just machines or yeah you know
everyone's just driven by self-interest
and that's pretty much the whole the
whole game that's a very paltry
conception of spirit doesn't even map on
to our experience very well right people
have to do a lot of self-talk in order
to keep thinking those sorts of things
they have to keep watching the the right
videos to put them in the right frame of
mind and keep giving themselves pep
talks about how the whole world is just
a bunch of selfish people well if you
have a that that's going to be a fairly
easy to work with thing you're not going
to need a hell of a lot of mental
properties to explain things but the bad
side of that is you won't actually be
explaining much of a feeling will you
and that's going to be reflected in an
easier job over here he says the more
paltry the the can
ception a spirit the mental properties
become fewer and partly did they become
more detached rigid and ossified
therefore more akin to characteristics
of the bone much more comparable with
them people who want to do a sort of
mechanistic materialistic reduction who
love that sort of thing see what their
psychology looks like it's often quite
impoverished it can't really take
account of our experience or at least
the experience of those of us who don't
constantly dim this sort of thing into
our ears it becomes something more like
just a bunch of parts together in the
skull or you know tissues right he goes
only says although the task is made much
easier by this there still remains a lot
of work to be done on both sides there
remains for observation the entire
contingency of their relation that's the
fundamental problem the entire
contingency of their relation why is
this part of the brain connected with
this part of the skull there's an easy
answer to that well it's close to it in
vicinity why is this mental property
connected with this part of the brain
and thereby connected with this part of
the skull no explanation it just is that
way it fell out that way that's what
contingency quite literally means comes
from the word to fall you know you throw
the dice they fall down that way there
you go no further explanation that's
deeply unsatisfying for any genuine
psychology anyone who really wants to
make sense out of things so he goes on
he's got this great example of the
children of Israel right says that the
children of Israel who are likened in
number to the sands of the sea shore
should each take upon to himself the
grain of Sandwich stood for him the
indifference in arbitrariness of such a
procedure would be no more glaring than
that which assigns to every faculty of
souls every passion and what must
equally be considered here every nuance
of character which a more refined
psychology and knowledge of human nature
likes to talk about its particular area
of skull and shape of skull bone because
it signs to it
particular part of the brain and thereby
a particular part of the skull the more
complex the more adequate to reality to
the lived reality of experience that our
psychology gets the more difficult the
task of coordination gets to make up
figure out where on all these parts of
the skull this is going to map on Jim
now he points out a further problem with
this right so let's say you could
actually do that and let's say you
didn't do it with parts of the skull
let's say instead you did it with MRI
scans I mean put aside the fact that
turns out that there there's some
inherent problems with the programs that
were doing the MRI scans for over a
decade let's say all that problem didn't
exist we're going to do MRI scans and
we're going to get over the problem of
taking human beings and putting them
inside of these essentially tanks which
are going to already affect the brain
state of the person and let's just
imagine that we have a technology that
allows us to do brain scanning in a very
very sophisticated way of people as
they're walking around doing their thing
going up to the podium and giving a
presentation making love eating their
meals yelling at you know children in
the street fervor you know crossing
against traffic all these sorts of
things right imagine that that that's a
big leap right there I don't know when
such technology will ever exist probably
not in my lifetime but just imagine it
now would that actually reveal to us any
more than the phrenology with its parts
of the skull the true nature of the
human person and all of the mental
properties all the passions all of the
particular experiences we like to think
that it does but does it do we really
have solid not just evidence but a
reasoning an account to make sense of
that there's a problem of what we call
overdetermination when we see
an event happening we're trying to get
away from the brain when we see an event
happening there's multiple ways to
understand that event that's why you
know thinkers like Thomas Aquinas would
say it's very important to attend how
you describe an action because an action
can be described in multiple ways is
that man stealing the loaf of bread or
is that man taking something in order to
feed his family maybe both maybe neither
maybe one more than the other maybe one
of these is more adequate well we have
to be similarly careful when we talk
about what's going on in the brain
there's an electrical impulse happening
and there's certain neurons connected
together well that could be anger in
that person or that could be excitement
or that could be a memory of a time when
they were embarrassed or that could and
we can go on and on and on you see how
that happens similarly with the skull
stuff and this is much more crude back
in hegel's time he says let's take the
skulls of murderers right the skull of a
murderer he has not this organ or even
signed but but a bump a bump somewhere
but this murderer also has a multitude
of other properties just as he has other
bumps and along with bombs also hollows
one as a choice of bumps and hollows and
again his murderous disposition can be
related to any bumper hollow and this in
turn to any mental property for the
murderer is nearly neither merely this
abstraction of a murderer nor does he
have only one bump and howl two ways to
look at this one is we can say well
being a murderer is a much larger scale
property than say having this particular
mental property could be that there's
certain mental properties that are that
are tied in with being a murderer I can
think of several offhand
anger-management problems right it would
probably lend itself to being a murderer
although there's no guarantee right I
got anger-management problems I haven't
killed anybody willing to bet that you
know good portion of the people watching
this can say the same thing about
themselves right
and maybe a lack of regard for human
life egoism any of these sorts of things
these are themselves though huge huge
complexes of mental properties as well
but let's say we get get over that
problem right if we can say that being a
murderer is a matter of multiple things
then we've got to look for all those
multiple things and we have to see those
reflected in the brain and then we have
to see those reflected in the skull in
order to be able to say well this person
is definitely a murderer even with you
know the crime itself we say well they
have to have you know motive opportunity
cause that motive and opportunity and
means sorry or you know there's other
ways to parse it as well it's not quite
so simple similarly you know a person is
a poet why because he's got this bump on
his head or this recess in his head I
don't have you ever tried writing poetry
it's not quite so simple it's just you
know activating a certain part in your
brain right there's a lot more involved
in it than the man certainly if you want
to write good poetry which I've only
done a few times in my life written
plenty of bad poetry so there's this
problem of over determination we also
don't even know really where to look
when it comes to the skull is it this
bump or this bump or this bump if we
could do statistical correlations and
say when I the you know if you've ever
seen these 19th century monographs on
the physiological criminal type put
aside all the racism that's involved in
them right off the bat and let's say we
just focus on you know skull shape or
something like that is there really a
correlation that we can make a true
relation something like a law between
being a criminal type and then having a
skull-shaped in certain ways no and
Hegel goes on and he says here's here's
the problem the observations indulged in
on this point must just for that reason
sound is sensible as these people that
we talked about earlier
the dealer and the housewife who talked
about rain at the annual fair and on
washday the dealer just to remind
herself says oh yeah whenever there's
the annual fair day and always rains on
me and the housewife's then says yeah
whenever I hang out my laundry to dry it
always always rains on me too totally
arbitrary totally villachor in hegel's
term so he says dealer and housewife
might as well make the observation it
always rains when a particular neighbor
goes by or when they eat roast pork rain
is indifferent to circumstances like
these so two from the standpoint of
observation a particular determinate
pneus of spirit is indifferent to a
particular formation of the skull says
one is a dry sapless being for itself
and the ossified property of spirit the
other is equally sapless being in itself
such an ossified thing as both is are
completely indifferent to everything
else it's as just as much a matter of
indifference to the high bump whether a
murder is in its vicinity as it is to
the murder whether flatness is close by
him so what is Hagel staying here again
we've got this the we're going to boil
it down to terms arbitrariness of the
relation / determination of any presume
'add relation between these this is a
pretty damning blow against phrenology
it's also revealing to us it's not
purely critical it's revealing to us a
little bit about how we ought to think
about ourselves as spirit
you